you've got kick ass too so tell us about
that it's very exciting i mean iíve Nona
but that's obviously for a long time
because really kick-ass one was really
really cheap to make you like people
don't realize sometimes I think they
think it's the Iron Man or something you
know but we did it on a micro-budget it
was done for like 20 million dollars and
it made a hundred million theatrically
and then 140 million on DVD so on of 28
million investment 240 coming back means
there's going to be a sequel and ended
with a cliffhanger we wanted to do a
sequel and we wanted it to make a lot
more than a dead you know I mean it made
a hundred million dollars which is great
on a small budget but we really feel the
movie was awesome you know and we
thought it was going to do two three
four hundred million you know but what
it is is it's the that year it was the
second most illegally downloaded movie
and it's the number seven was the
legally downloaded movie of all time so
it's beltless cannabase between DVD and
pirates that we actually think it's
going to be let off steam power that the
second one is just going to explode and
cinemas it's going to be crazy because
heck I wasn't going to icon then things
you know I was a Halloween last year and
I saw two people like different people
dress the tech girl like walking around
going to end pubs and things and you
just think efforts f it seeped into that
level of public consciousness you know
that as something that's really
something there so I think kick-ass 2 is
very exciting we've normal doing it for
ages Jeff get hand-picked a year and a
half ago Matthew has long admired Jeff
and like this after the screenplay maybe
eight months ago and the final
screenplay was done maybe two months
banks so so everybody was really happy
and the thing is n interviews people
obviously what's going on make a caster
and I'm like yeah the guys on the screen
planar and everybody else is more coy
about it but I always just come out and
see what's actually i think you know and
then nothing happens for months but
obviously to have the fetish screenplay
now that universals approved and
everything and the dead two months ago
many were doing that it's obviously
going to watch for a long time you know
these things don't pop up in the world
so how close he'd been working with Jeff
on that well Jeff Jeff said you know I
did the comic passed down all the
scripts to Jeff and Jeff took as much as
he wants it seems Matthew died in the
freshman dinner and like you know Jeff
escapes I'd see maybe a bit eighty
percent of the car maker or something
you know which is great you know how
much of that ends up in the final movie
how much gets rewritten back in you
never know but at the moment
it's pretty much a clear adaptation of
the book which is great you know I mean
I was happy with the books I'm happy
they've kept all her stuff and like
Matthew and Jean I think he's added
little flourishes that actually make it
even better I'd like I I'm very happy
with the kick-ass comic but i actually
prefer the movie i think they did such a
great job on it and I like the feeling
that k cast is going to be the same I
think the movie will probably be there
so who are we talking about returning in
terms of course and the kick-ass 2 and I
think right now we're not allowed to see
because it's just the you know
technically agents haven't signed off on
certain things or whatever but basically
you know we want the proper cast you
know I mean it'd be weird to do it
without Khloe in arden and cress you
know and but there's two other rules in
this movie there keep bringing another
name actors like well we obviously don't
have nicolas cage because he died in the
first one and but there's a character
called the colonel and this movie here's
a kinnor older guy who starts like in a
neighborhood watch give a thing you know
which is a bunch of people dressed up as
superheroes patrolling part of New York
which is actually happening in your life
just now you know I think new yours get
150 different people doing mazuma so and
there's another maybe another role as
well this character called Nate [ __ ]
which sounds horrible but there's a
skeleton Nate [ __ ] that as I possible
can i name role in there too so in over
the next can a couple of weeks we get
all that nailed down because we're
filming really soon What's it feel like
when you see those people walking around
at halloween wreath on port in the cost
to you and the characters you've written
yeah that's actually amazing like I mean
as a kids you know I grew up a spider
month or Hulk and I like anything you
know and and you know you almost can't
think that one time they just existed in
someone's head because know there's such
global icons so as ecology I don't think
of myself in the same bracket someone
like Stan Lee or Jack Kirby you know who
made those characters that you forget in
1959 those characters doesn't exist
those Marvel characters know they're
suddenly everywhere so as quite exciting
seeing these comics that I'm doing just
now one by one or becoming films and
becoming the Rowan little kind of
probably with the marvel universe was in
the LA sex tejan are just very quickly
catching fire like and suddenly becoming
movies is most exciting thing in the
world I mean for me I'd see even more
exciting was probably setting in my
house and seeing a bus go by the window
and seeing the kick-ass ad on the side
of a bus and it was the same bus by my
house all the time and it was just it
was really odd or the football stadium
in my hometown has a big billboard
beside it and to see the wanted poster
there a couple of years back and in the
kickass wine after was just so exciting
is as
it's less exciting seeing it in Los
Angeles or something because you don't
have at the same point of reference but
to see it in your own home town is
actually out of your bars it's great so
can we expect maybe a kick-ass 3 after
this film as well well for anyone who's
read the book and kick-ass 2 ends on a
cliffhanger and i purposely did that to
get kicker's you know baby this is this
is basically the Star Wars trilogy you
know like kick-ass one set everyone up
you know that was the farm boy in
Tatooine can I becoming a hero you know
kick-ass 2 is what it goes dark and it's
like Matthews like George Lucas playing
in an Irving cashman he's brought in
jeff wadlow you know and this is the
dark one you know and things would get
really bad for all the heroes and it
ends with their equivalent of Han Solo
frozen in carbonite you know that as I
can a cliffhanger ending and then the
third one is when everything goes nice
again you know and and by that point
kick-ass is quite a different character
from he was from the first one the real
Luke Skywalker was he's been on this
kind of Germany so it's always planned
to stream of these three books and three
movies
you